Congressman George Santos says he is not
going anywhere but some of his fellow
Republicans on Capitol Hill have joined
the demands for him to resign Santos has
admitted lying about his life story
during his campaign and he faces
multiple ethics complaints Caitlyn Huey
Burns is here with the latest on this
story Caitlin good morning to you Mr
Santos continues to just double down yes
indeed and this is a story that seems to
be evolving by the day and one of the
latest developments is that Republican
officials here in New York who actually
helped Santos get elected are now
demanding that he stepped down but in
Washington Party leaders on Capitol Hill
say the voters should decide if he stays
or goes
is it national joke he's an
international joke but this joke's got
to go Republican leaders in the New York
County that embattled Congressman George
Santos represents are urging him to
resign George Santos to me is a bunch of
Lies Joe kairo chairs the Nassau County
GOP and helped to vet Santos he made
statements we believed him we trusted
him it was all a falsehood but so far
Santos says he's not going anywhere
I will not the floodgates are now open
on Wednesday four Republican congressmen
from New York called for Santos to
resign including representative Anthony
desposito I wanted to make it very clear
that that is not our brand that's not
what we stand for Santos has already
admitted he lied about his education
work history and claims his grandparents
fled the Holocaust but he still refuses
to answer how he financed his campaign a
CBS News Review revealed contributions
of more than ten thousand dollars from a
controversial Chinese donor and more
than eighteen thousand dollars from the
cousin of a sanctioned Russian oligarch
you know in America today you're
innocent to proven guilty the GOP has a
razor-thin majority in the house and
despite calls from some fellow
Republicans to Aus Santos speaker Kevin
McCarthy said he still has plans to seat
him on a congressional committee voters
who made that decision he has to answer
to the voters and the voters to make
another decision but Cairo says Santos
no longer has a political future yeah
we're done with him I feel sorry and sad
for him that he has lived certainly for
the past few years this life of Lies
totally untrue and it's very sad and
perhaps pathetic but the people deserve
more
and CBS News has obtained the resume
that Santos gave to Republican Party
leaders in his County and guys this is
really stunning he claims to have had a
3.89 GPA and he also told Cairo who we
spoke to Cairo told us that he said that
he was a star volleyball player at a
college that he never attended so the
lies yeah just keep they're so Random
Caitlyn and it's not just a volleyball
player he's a star volleyball player so
what are the voters saying we see what
the politicians are saying do you know
what is the people who actually voted
for him are saying well you know we were
spending time in his district yesterday
and Republicans there who have been
supporting him feel duped they also feel
like you know he lied to them he
presented a different story and also
that this story has become so big that
it's taking away from issues that they
care about they said he campaigned on
issues like the economy and inflation
nobody's talking about that and they're
kind of concerned about how he can do
his job I don't know how he continues to
stay I really don't I mean he he's doing
things that we teach our children not to
do yeah well one important Dynamic to
consider here politically at least is
that Kevin McCarthy's majority in
Congress is so narrow that he really
does need every last vote and he Santos
helped win them that majority by
flipping a seat yeah even if it was a
House of Lies he was voted in Caitlyn
thank you so much